المخاوف من الذكاء الاصطناعي انحصرت خلال
الاشهر الماضيه بين صفوف الاكاديميين
واروقت المدارس القلق الاكبر حينها كان غش
الطلاب لكن يبدو ان ما تنطوي عليها بتقنيه
من مخاطر يفوق ذلك بكثير فسام التمان رئيس
شركه اوبن اي اي لذكاء الاصطناعي التي
تصنع
مخاوفه معترفا بانها قد تضر العالم التمان
حذر من مخاطر انظمه الذكاء للصناعه
المتزايده مشددا على ضروره كبحها وتخفيف
من مخاطرها عبر تدخل حكوميا حاسب اقترح
تشكيله وكاله امريكيه او عالميه ترخص
انظمه ذكاء الاصطناعي على ان تتمتع بسلطه
سحب هذا الترخيص وضمان الامتثال لمعايير
السلامه اما الضمانات حسب التمان فتشمل
تنظيم عمل نماذج الذكاء الاصطناعي التي
يمكنها التكرار الذاتي التسلل الذاتي في
اشاره الى مخاوف تلاعب تلك الانظمه
المتقدمه بالبشر
وحتى السيطره عليهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات